after helping jump-start the market for
electric cars right speed CEO Ian Wright
now wants to help build electric powered
trucks and we're talking about not
pickups Ian but trucks that haul things
we saw the video of that big sort of
18-wheeler rig drifting and in the
desert so that's a great video
I loved this when it first hit the
internet it went viral right away but
what are you using to power that is it
just electric motors it's high power
electric motors plus a range extender
which is a gas turbine generator and why
a gas turbine generator I mean the idea
of putting a turbine on a car it's kind
of like it's a very 60s kind of Batman
thing that never really picked up as is
this video where it appears that the
helicopter is about to land the
helicopter pilot was crazy
so yeah they tried to mines in cars in
the 60s but they tried to drive the
wheels with them and you can't do that
because turbines are only efficient at
full power and most of the time cars run
at very low power so the fuel
consumption was horrible interaction
would be pretty difficult and control is
another problem yes behind that but now
that we've got high power batteries and
high power electric motors then we can
drive the vehicle with the electric
motors with efficiency right across the
range and then the turbine is just
driving a generator keeping the
batteries charged and that means we can
run the turbine at its most efficient
operating point until the batteries fall
and then shut it down so we don't care
that it's not efficient unless you
essentially use the turbine as a range
extender that we see in for example BMW
i3 they use a range extender but this is
much more fuel-efficient than powerful
once you can do it then the reasons to
use a turbine are it's about it since
the weight for the same power and it's
at least 10 times better in fuel
efficient all right so this all sounds
great how far along is it how far are we
from having this actually rolled out in
scale in commercial trucks so we have a
couple of FedEx trucks on the road now
for 18 months we were going to deliver
our first garbage truck in a couple of
months Wow you have any sense of how
much FedEx is saving on fuel I can't
really talk about that but in garbage
trucks we saved about $35,000 a year in
fuel about 20,000 the maintenance so we
saved more than half
fuel and more than half the emissions
per truck per truck so $35,000 a year
per truck oh they burn fifty five to
sixty thousand dollars a year in fuel
Wow garbage trucks come in fourteen
thousand gallons what do you say to
people who say actually electric cars
aren't so green because nobody knows how
to deal with Oh No so because then
because you need to use mostly coal
powered plants to generate the
electricity yeah well that's true that's
true
and so in fact we say that our system is
cleaner than an Eevee because that
turbine engine has lower emissions than
the average mix of power stations in the
US so you'll have lower emissions if you
don't plug it in the you burn fuel in
the turbine right depending obviously on
how you charge your electric car I mean
if you use solar power to charge well
you could have put that into the grid so
mm-hmm all right so so you're getting
actual corporate customers that are
using this where do you want to go with
it where you see the future of and by
the way the technology is called the
fulcrum right which is a cool name for a
turbine gas turbine that's the tip on
generator yes so we plan to dominate the
power train space in these kind of
trucks so imagine if one of the diesel
engine manufacturers came out and said
hey you know we've been struggling to
get 3% 5% improvement and fuel
efficiency and emissions we've got a new
new powertrain technology that will give
you 60% improvement in fuel efficiency
60% improvement and emissions same
performance wouldn't that change the
world it would it was very interesting
stuff thank you so much Ian for joining
us
Ian right their CEO bright speed he also
designed by the way an electric car I
think the fastest electric car in the
world yes zero to 60 in 2.9 seconds sis
that's pretty amazing